Thanks everyone for joining. First of all, thanks to the organizers for putting
together a session on metabolism and metastasis.
And I know the concomitant talks on one
memorial on Michael Bishop and another one on KRAS inhibitors that
are happening just at this time, so I really appreciate that you decided
to come here instead.
So we will get going.
I will just do a very brief introduction of today's session, and
there will be three speakers, myself, and we have Dr.
Pankaj Singh talking about nucleotide metabolism in the
context of cancer and metastasis.
And finally, Ralph DeBerardinis, who's going to tell us about
NAD+ T5 and new roles for this hydrolase actually, which is
beyond its canonical
roles. I'm really looking forward to hearing from him.
So why
metastasis and why metabolism metastasis?
If you ask me, I would say we've been
studying wrong models of cancer for many, many years.
Most of the mouse models that we've been using and most
of the samples we've been collecting from patients
through the years has been on primary tumors.
And that's the biology we've been learning again and again
throughout the last four or five decades.
When actually how cells metastasize,
it requires a completely different biology.
First of all, for cells to leave their primary tumors,
move through circulation, and get to the new niche, and being able to
first establish in this new niche and grow, requires a
completely different set of biological pathways.
And for years we've been collecting biopsies on primary tumors from patients.
You will not learn about that biology by studying those primary
tumors. The same with cancer models in mice. Why?
Because it's expensive. We don't want to wait long.
Most of our animal models develop very aggressive primary tumors, and those are
the ones we've been studying. So it took really
a change in mindset for the fields to realize that we
need both to start collecting samples from patients, metastatic
sample from patients, and
animal models that allow us to study metastatic disease.
And although we've been learning through the years about these first three
stages here, intravasation, latency, and then
extravasation to establishing the new niche, how these
micrometastasis establish in the new niche and how they start growing remain
mostly unknown.
Within the adaptations that happen in metastasis, how
metabolism changes in those cells remain even
most unknown than in primary tumors.
And that was the reason to organize this session.
We believe the field is now ripe
to be learning on unique
metabolic adaptations in metastatic cells, and
this is what
this session today is about.
So I will get started.
And I will tell you about the work that my laboratory has been
doing for the past, I would say, few years.
I will give a very brief introduction on our work.
Some of you may know that I work on sirtuins for many years,
but we've been studying metastatic adaptation for the past few years,
and that's what I'm going to tell you today.
And I wish I had time to tell you how I took that picture in the Grand Canyon.
This was two years ago, and I got two prizes for this picture, so I
am now not an amateur photographer anymore.
So my laboratory has been studying this connection between metabolism
and chromatin for many years. I call it an obvious link.
This is two fields that for many people
have been separated for too many years.
People studying chromatin biology stuck to the nucleus and try
to purify chromatin enzymes that were important to regulate
chromatin
pathways without looking outside of the nucleus, and vice versa.
People studying metabolic adaptation, they mutually stuck to the mitochondria,
sometimes into the cytoplasm. Definitely, they don't
get into the nucleus when they think about metabolic adaptations.
But as exemplified here in a couple of
diagrams, we cannot modify chromatin if we don't have
metabolites to do it.
Every single chemical chromatin
modification requires metabolites.
And here is example of S-Adenosyl methionine, SAM for
methylation reactions. You cannot methylate DNA or histones if you
don't have enough quantities of SAM, a major metabolite in
many metabolic pathways. You cannot acetylate histones if you
don't have acetyl-CoA, another major metabolite in many,
many different metabolic pathways.
And thirdly, you don't only need metabolites to directly
modify chromatin, some of these metabolites are used as co-factor
by chromatin enzymes. And one example is NAD, another
major metabolite in multiple metabolic pathways that is used as a co-factor
by many chromatin enzymes, among other sirtuins
and PARP. And that's how my laboratory got
introduced to that connection between metabolism and chromatin.
This is a very brief summary of what the lab has been doing for many
years. I won't have time to show you.
I will need five days to go through all the projects that
we are doing currently in the lab. But for many years, as I said, we work on this
sirtuin called SIR6. It's an histone deacetylase, and we publish role for
SIR6 as a modulator of glycolysis, of metabolism
in cancer, particularly on primary tumors.
We haven't studied its role in metastasis before.
More recently, we became interested in other metabolic adaptations of cancer,
and here are two examples. I will tell you today, I hope I
have time, a few slides on a
unique adaptation on one-carbon metabolism.
And I won't have time to show you today on another project in the lab where we
are studying how cells detoxify nuclear
formaldehyde. And the same formaldehyde that all of you use as a
cross-linker in your chemical reactions is produced endogenously
by chromatin enzymes. And we still don't know how it is detoxified in the nucleus.
I won't have time to tell you about today.
My lab is still interested in chromatin roles in DNA repair, and we
recently published a paper on a new factor that is important in a human
syndrome, and you're welcome to go and look at the
paper.But as I
said, this is about metabolic adaptation in metastasis, and
this is what we've been doing for the past few years.
And the model we decided to study or start studying with
is pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma, PDAC. Why?
Because first of all, it remains one of the most lethal cancers that we
have, and at time of diagnosis, most of the patients will
already have metastatic disease.
And metastasis is what kills 90% to 95% of our
patients when they come to the clinic.
And as I said, we still know much less biologically
about how metastasis develop.
Very few cells manage to get away from the primary
tumors to survive in circulation, and even less to
establish in the new niche.
And a couple of papers we were finishing a study on
pancreatic cancer models with SIL6 in 2016.
Thereafter, two papers came out in Nature Genetics, one from
the work of Bert Vogelstein and Cristina Coccio, and the other from Andrew
Feinberg, who is receiving this afternoon the Klaus Award that Ralph
will be introducing him to.
And in both of these papers, this was the first genomic comparison
of primary tumors against metastatic disease
pair-matched from patients. And the surprise for both of these
studies were that when they look for genetic alterations, they didn't see
extra genetic alteration in the metastatic cells.
So for these metastatic cells to grow, they still maintain the same
genetic drivers that the primary tumors carry, but they didn't acquire new
genetic adaptations. And actually, Andrew Feinberg went one step further.
He said, "Most of what I see are chromatin changes, and a lot of these are
on genes that are metabolic genes." So this was descriptive.
They just look at the genetics of sequencing of these patients.
We have the right models to study what was changing in these
pancreatic cancers in the metastatic
tissues that were non-genetically happening.
So, as I said, we developed a pancreatic cancer model, and we're to study
SIL6 as a tumor suppressor. Eliminating SIL6 make those tumors much,
much more aggressive, because it was driving a metabolic adaptation in the
primary tumors. But an important point, and this was if you cross it to a
K-RAS alone, which almost never get you tumors, but even in the
context of K-RAS p53. In both cases, these animals
develop extremely aggressive disease.
And beyond what we saw in the primary tumors, what for us was striking,
the animals developed, for almost 50% of them, liver and lung
metastasis. And it remains one of the few pancreatic cancer models of
lung metastasis today.
Because we knew that these animals developed the mets so rapidly, we
hypothesized this could be a very good model to study what is changing in these
metastatic cells that it's not genetically driven.
So we collected, when a postdoc joined my lab, Cristina Ferrer,
I told her, "Let's work with PDAC." She came from a breast
cancer model lab, and she said that we can do the same on breast cancer.
When we inject primary tumors, in weeks, these animals develop
lung metastasis. So we'll have a parallel model in a different
tumor to study how these metastatic cells come up.
So we collected RNA from every one of these tissues, primary, lymph node,
and the mets.
We got a beautiful Venn diagram, and many people has been doing this, and
this Venn diagram gave us a lot of different interesting genes, some that were
specific to liver, some that were lung specific from
both type of tumors, and some that were
same primary origin, different metastatic site.
We decided to start with what we call the common metastatic signature,
because we needed to start somewhere, and this was a collection of
genes that were up and down in every single metastasis, independent of
the tissue of origin, independent of the tissue of the met.
Now, many people, as I said, have been doing this.
We went one step further, and we decided to do a high-throughput sulforaphane
assay to validate from all of these genes how many of those
are exclusively going up in the mets and driving the
growth of these metastatic cells.
And we started with a sulforaphane assay because it has higher stringency.
And when we did, it worked beautifully. This was a 96-well plate.
For most of the genes, we saw no effect.
For some of them, when we inactivated them by knockdown,
the colonies disappear.
So this was the list, was less than 10 genes.
We further validated them by many different methods that I won't have time to
tell you today. But from this list, we've been, and that's why the title
of my talk is One Gene at a Time. We've been trying to understand how these
unique genes are up or down in the metastasis.
Specifically, what are they doing to allow these metastatic cells to
grow? And this is the top genes here on the left,
and I will tell you a story of few of these genes today.
The first one is GSTT1. This is a glutathione
transferase. When you think about glutathione, you immediately think about
antioxidant adaptations. This is not the case for
GSTT1. This is a transferase, so it conjugates
glutathione to things. It's only almost exclusively
expressed in the liver as a detoxifying enzyme. Okay?
It conjugates glutathione to drugs, so we eliminate the drugs from
our system. Endogenous substrate for glutathione in
GSTT1 remains unknown, and roles for GSTT1 in
cancer are also unknown. So we decided to study this,
and we first confirmed the expression levels.
You can see here in our own mouse model,
and this is from the rapid autopsy program at MGH from human
patients. GSTT in green, we see no expression in the
primary tumors, massive upregulation in both the liver and the lung mets.
So exclusively expressed in the mets, no expression in the primary tumors, and here
it's validated by Western.2D growth, as I said,
no effect on 2D if we eliminate. This is we see here CRISPR
to eliminate GSTT1, we eliminate it with dox-inducible, no effect on
2D. In 3D, the colonies completely disappear.
And in vivo, the same phenotype. If we inject these cells into
animals, the primary tumors grows unabated, and
we expect that because there was no expression of GSTT1 to start with, so these
primary tumors don't care, but the metastasis disappear.
And here you can see in the lung, there is not even micro metastasis, a
massive phenotype for this unique enzyme.
It's not only required but also sufficient.
If we overexpress GSTT1 on these cells and then we inject the cells into mice,
we start getting ectopic metastasis in places where we never see
metastasis. In here, including the skull mass, the shoulder mass, the ribs,
and much more in the liver and the lung.
So it's both required and sufficient as a driver of metastatic
growth.
How is GSTT1 working? Again, I won't go through a lot of data
that took us to get here, but I will just show you the
biochemistry. We use classic biochemistry to IP
either GSTT1 interactors of glutathione-related proteins
to try to identify things that are glutathione-related and
interacting with GSTT1. And the mass spec, and
many of the things that came down were extracellular matrix proteins.
We focus on fibronectin 1, because it's a well-known
major protein from the extracellular matrix.
And we show that it interacts with GSTT1.
And if you
inhibit GSTT1, FN1 cannot be secreted
from the cancer cells, which for us was a surprise.
Most of the people believe that fibronectin is secreted by the tumor-associated
fibroblasts. Our cell studies
identify fibronectin as being glutathione-related, is a new
modification on fibronectin, and secreted by this
modification, secreted from the cancer cells, not the tumor-associated
fibroblasts. And in this model of GSTT1 overexpression, where that
I told you produce massive ectopic metastasis, if we
inactivate FN1, the metastasis disappear.
So I don't think it's the only substrate, but it's clearly a dominant
substrate downstream of GSTT1.
So
we published this paper last year in "Nature Cell Biology,"
and you are welcome to go and check the paper
for more details about it. And what I'm going to tell you now are about two more
stories that are downstream of that screen that are unpublished.
The first is on an amino acid transporter, which is called SLC30A4.
It was actually among the tops from our screen, and if you look
at, and this is in two independent
RNA-Seq from humans studies, the top upregulated
gene was SLC30A4 in this one, and clearly
upregulated in the second dataset from the Morphy group.
This is the only, unfortunately, I love chromatin.
I trained as a chromatin biologist, but my lab is doing much more
metabolism that I was hoping for at this stage of my
career. So this is the only chromatin figure I will show
you, and this is from the original paper from Andrew Feinberg, where you can see
that in the metastasis, the gene itself, SLC30A4, is
chromatin marks of activity, of active chromatin marks,
H3K4 methylation and H3K27 acetylation are
actually increasing signal in the promoter of these genes.
So it is regulated epigenetically.
And how, we can talk another three hours about, we believe we have
some answers on how these genes are upregulated in a coordinated manner
by an epigenetic factor.
But we decided to study SLC30A4. It's a poorly studied amino acid
transporter, transmembrane domains, only expressed also in
the liver, in normal cells, and it's a transport of many different amino
acids. Mostly neutral amino acids, under changes in
pH can also go to other amino acids, but it's really pretty
broad in its preference. So for us was a surprise
why the cells will uniquely upregulate this amino acid
transporter.
I will go very fast, and this is the same I show you for GSTT1 when
we do IF. Primary tumors in our mouse and
in humans show basically no expression, but both liver and lung,
massive upregulation of expression for SLC30A4 quite
broadly.
We did the 2D, and we saw no changes in growth in 2D,
but a clear decrease in colonies and in spheres, in tumor spheres in
culture if you inactivate SLC30A4,
and the cells are dying from apoptosis by how we saw the increase in
cleaved caspase-3.
In vivo, the same as I show you for GSTT1.
Primary tumors don't care, and they shouldn't, because we saw no
expression of this amino acid transporter in primary
tumors, but the metastasis completely disappear.
So it's another gene for which the metastatic cells are
upregulating it, and they become addicted to this transport.
So what is SLC30A4 transporting? And so within
metabolomics, and for my surprise, actually, when we look what was changing,
the only thing when we overexpress SLC30A4 that was
actually uptake more was serine,
the serine amino acid. And we validated this by using
a label serine, 15N label serine on these cells, and we saw a
clear upregulation of serine uptake
on cells that
we overexpress SLC30A4. This was for me, as I said, a surprise
because this amino acid can transport many amino acids.
Of course, the cells express a lot of other transporters, and for some
reason, they uniquely upregulate these two uptake
serine.So we decided to test,
first of all, how much metastatic cells care about exogenous
serine. And it was clear on every cell line that we tested,
although
in 2D growth, when we have excess of serine in just media, in 2D
growth, they don't care
if you remove serine from the media, and I will come back to that.
But in 3D, these metastatic cells cannot grow if you don't have
exogenous serine. And so both through the upregulation of the
transporter and the presence of exogenous serine, these cells manage to grow.
And we can give the cells permeable serine, and we fully rescue
growth if we do that. So if you don't have the transporter, but you give them
permeable serine, the cells manage to grow equally as the controls.
So for me, this was a surprise. Why?
Well, if you keep the literature, most of the papers that are out there show you
that serine, even though it's a non-essential amino acid, is a critical
amino acid for many, many metabolic reactions in the cell.
It's so critical that cancer cells
develop mechanism to synthetize serine, and
among them, the main papers by Karen Bowsen and Oliver
Maddox show that most of the primary
tumors upregulate or amplify specific enzymes in
the serine biosynthetic pathway.
Among them, PHGDH, which is upregulated in
KRAS-driven PDAC, and that upregulation of PHGDH
allows glucose to be converted into serine.
And she published all together with Oliver that this was a critical
adaptation, so the cancer cell primary tumors don't require
serine. So why these metastatic cells that are derived from these primary
tumors that are already having this adaptation
requires exogenous serine?
This is a separate paper showing that actually if you look at human PDAC lines,
many of them are serine addicted. So not all PDAC
lines actually
can upregulate the enzymes. And when you look at the lines, most of these are
actually metastatic lines.
When we look, and again, I don't have the full answer for this,
at some of the enzymes that are usually upregulated or amplified,
when you compare the primary tumors to the mets, the mets actually show a
clear inhibition of these enzymes.
So they lose the capability to express these enzymes, hence
becoming addicted or auxotrophic to the expression of the
transporter and to exogenous serine.
Why? We can go about it in another talk, but just
suffice here for the talk to say that they really lose the ability to synthesize
serine. They become addicted to serine uptake.
We know now some of the reason what is happening, but it's
still in progress, and it's not fully
rigorous tested yet for me to tell you.
But we believe we know why these cells lose this ability and why
they become addicted to exogenous serine.
And this is the first time in my career that we
try to move from a basic research finding to the
clinic. We decided to collaborate with Twist Biosciences to
develop antibodies against this transporter.
And this is the first screening, which you see here, the controls.
When you add dox, this is how much serine is uptaken.
And every one of these has dox. They should be as red as these
guys here. And you see a lot of yellow here.
This means that the presence of the antibodies are blocking the ability
of this transporter to uptake serine. So we're very excited about it.
We are moving with three of these top antibodies now, and hopefully to
convince some companies to give us millions so we
can develop these antibodies. I'm still looking for some
companies.
And I will finish with the last story today,
with only just few slides.
In parallel to these studies, a very talented postdoc in my lab,
Tiziano Bernaschi, who is sitting here in the audience,
decided to use the DepMap to check for
other dependencies in pancreatic cancer.
And when he was doing this analysis, and here what he's doing different from what
most people use DepMap for, he's comparing PDAC against other
cancers and look for things that are exclusively present as a dependency
in the context of PDAC disease.
To our surprise, one of the genes that was there was MAT2A.
And I didn't introduce it, I very rapidly mentioned it before, but
MAT2A is a rate-limiting enzyme in production of
SAM, S-adenosylmethionine, in one carbon metabolism.
So this, for us, was unique that we found this
specifically in the context of pancreatic cancer.
When we look further, and I don't have time to tell you, but
MAT2A has been related for some companies now
that are developing drugs to MTAP deletion, and only
cancers that have MTAP deletion will become sensitive to MAT2A.
We did the analysis here in the PDAC, and when we compare either MTAP
wild-type or MTAP knockout, we still saw the
dependency on MAT2A. So this was not dependent on MTAP
deletion. And when we look further on the analysis,
we realized that most of the lines that shows the dependency were
metastatic lines, not the primary ones.
So this was a unique adaptation of metastatic cells that appears to
become dependent on MAT2A. Now, if you look at copy
number variation, MAT2A is not that high.
And that's showing also MTAP there, that is actually without
dependency on MTAP. So we decided to investigate it further.
There is not much work done on one carbon metabolism in
pancreatic cancer. As I said, it's a rate-limiting enzyme
in
S-adenosylmethionine production, which is used for many things in the
cells, including methylation reactions, particularly on chromatin,
as I mentioned originally, on DNA and histone
methylation.So we took samples
from our
mouse models. I mentioned this briefly, our PDAC mouse model of aggressive disease,
where we can collect primary lung and liver mets, and we
stained for MAT2A activity with
presence. We thought that we will see increase in levels of MAT2A,
which is normally localized in the cytoplasm.
And to our surprise, we saw MAT2A in the cytoplasm in
primary tumors, but clearly moving into the
nucleus in the metastatic cells. That, for us, was a
surprise. One-carbon metabolism and definitely MAT2A has not
been described in the nucleus.
And this is a quantification there.
And when we look in actually sample from primary
human patients, from primary and pair liver mets, we saw the same
phenotype, a clear increase in nuclear staining for MAT2A.
Tiziano did something creative there.
He took sample from primary and mets.
We did metabolomics, and when we did metabolomics, we found that specific
metabolites in one-carbon pathway were actually
changing in the context of metastatic disease.
And I won't have time to show you which ones and why,
but what we did is taking this information and creating a media
that mimic the conditions we saw in the metastatic cells, in
the tissue microenvironment. We call it metastatic-like media, MLM,
which hopefully will stick.
And when we took that MLM media and put the cells to grow,
we were able to see a very nice rescue of
growth on cells that are growth in no
methionine. Okay? One of the metabolites that were clearly
going down was methionine in the mets.
When we take metastatic cells, and you remove methionine from
the media, basically, the cells cannot grow.
And actually, most of the cells cannot grow if you remove methionine.
But specifically, the metastatic cells, when you give them
homocystine, which was one of the main metabolites that was increased
in these met conditions, we saw rescue of growth in
these conditions.
Just a quantification.
Remarkably, under the same conditions, this is the MLM media, we saw a
massive
movement, localization of MAT2A into the
nucleus and on chromatin. So that change in media that
mimic metastatic condition was driving the movement of
MAT2A to the nucleus. So this told us that maybe MAT2A
is moving to the nucleus to produce some
in the nucleus in situ for methylation reactions in the
nucleus. Now, this is something that it has been shown beautifully for acetyl-CoA,
and many different laboratories, including those of Shelley Berger,
have shown that many enzymes in the acetyl-CoA pathway move
to the nucleus to produce acetyl-CoA in situ.
But that has never been shown for SAM.
Indeed,
not only we see MAT2A move into the nucleus, but under these conditions
here with no methionine but homocystine, that is the MLM media,
we see that the cells managed to maintain the methylation
of several of these histone marks.
So in order to specifically test whether that was a big
statement by Tiziano convincing me that this enzyme moved to the nucleus
to produce some insight too. So I told him, "If you want to convince me and the
reviewers, you need to do something extra." And he did a beautiful experiment.
He purified nuclei. You can maintain nuclei lives for a couple of
days, and he purified nuclei from either normal conditions or
metastatic cells, or either normal conditions of MLM grown cells.
And in both cases, when you purify the nuclei and you expose this nuclei
to label methionine, and you look to see,
are these cells now that you're having conditions to make SAM,
when you have the purified nuclei, can the purified nuclei
synthesize SAM?
And that was the case. We saw first the methionine from the labeling.
We saw the product of SAM as S-adenosylhomocysteine,
the homocysteine itself, which was not surprising
because we were giving it to the media, but we failed to detect SAM
in these conditions. So then we hypothesized maybe
SAM is utilized so rapidly by the histone and DNA
methyltransferases that we won't detect the label unless we
stop the reaction. And we added to the same in vitro nuclear
purification inhibitors of DNMT and inhibitor of histone
methyltransferases, and we saw a beautiful peak of SAM
label from the original 13C, confirming that these
enzymes are moving to the nucleus, and these are a four-step
reaction. Every one of these enzyme in the one carbon have to move to the nucleus
to produce SAM.
Where are we now? So this is an ongoing story.
So to convince reviewer, what I told him, "What we really need is to create a
system where you can express MAT2A only in the cytoplasm or only
in the nucleus." And that what he has done recently.
He succeeded in generating these tools, and as
I'm speaking now, he's been injecting
these cells into animals, and we believe that only the nuclear
one will be able to give metastasis because of this unique
adaptation, to obtain one SAM in the nucleus.
So with this, I will finish. This is just the diagram of what I show
you today,
one gene at a time. I know I was this morning in the plenary on AI,
that we don't need to do this anymore, that you can put everything on
a computer, go to lunch and come back, and the computer will do all
the experiments. I still am not fully
convinced. I think that we need some of us to go
about this one gene at a time, because understanding their function
will take more than just dropping things on a computer for the
computer to look at the literature.
So these are three of the genes we've been characterizing, and hopefully,
in the next year, I could show you more on the
antibodies that we are developing for SLT3A1.With this, I
will stop. And actually, I want to finish.
We can discuss this at the discussion time at the end.
We need to build better models. I think our model's failing
giving us a good model to study metastatic disease, and
we will discuss at the end about it.
And these are all the people in my lab and a lot of collaborators that allow
me to do this work, and we have fun also, not
only hard work
in the lab. With this, I will stop and take questions.
Yes, Ralu, you can start.
Yes, please.
Or at the end, I don't know.
Great talk, Dr. Matuszewski.
I'm curious for the three target, let's say.
So you're mentioning, I find very fascinating that it doesn't
affect the growth of the primary tumors,
but then it affect the growth of the metastasis.
So at which point do you think the expression is induced?
Or
does that mean that it's not involved in
MET?
MET, yeah. Excellent question. I can tell you that
based on how we build the model, remember, we were comparing macromets,
RNA-seq to lymph nodes and primary tumors, and we focus on
things that were exclusively up in the macromets.
By definition, we were looking at things that were only there upregulated.
And we went back, we had access to CTC, circulating
tumor cells, RNA-seq, and in none of the genes that we've been following,
we see upregulation at the CTCs level.
So the cells that managed to escape from the primary tumors
circulate, extravasate.
These genes are not required for any of these steps.
Once they establish in the new niche,
at least for GSTT1, these are called disseminated tumor cells,
and people define them as dormant cells.
In the original paper, we called them dormant cells.
We saw the GSTT1 upregulated at that stage, and we
explained that actually the remodeling of the extracellular matrix through
glutathionylation of fibronectin was exclusively for these
cells to
avoid clearance from the immune system.
So at least for GSTT1, we see clearly expression at the DTC
stage, which is the first stage where these cells impact in the new
niche. For SLC38A4, we don't know.
We know that the macrometastasis start expressing. We don't know if it's earlier.
What induced the overexpression of these genes?
So we've been looking, I told you we got thousands of these gene
changes up and down. So we can go back and look at motifs
upstream of the promoter to see if there are particular common transcription
factors that are driving the expression. And we identify a few.
One of them was Fos, one member of the AP1 family, which many people are
looking as potential drivers of cancer and
metastasis. We've been focusing on second one that is too new for me
to tell you. But we did find few transcription factors that are
uniquely up and we believe are coordinately regulating the
expression of these genes.
Impressive. And I wonder if
inducible knockout would help to answer,
like you let the tumor to be installed-
Yes
... and then see-
We have done that for GSTT1. We use the inducible model, and we saw that even
in the context of an inducible model where we waited for the tumors to develop,
and then we inhibit the GSTT1, only the metastasis went down.
Was very specific for the mets. We are doing it now for SLC38A4.
Okay. Impressive. Thank you so much.
My pleasure.
Excellent talk.
About 50 years ago, methionine dependency was identified by
Robert Hoffman and led to this concept that
patients should eat a methionine-depleted diet.
Have you thought about that as a strategy for preventing
metastatic progression?
Yeah, of course. Of course, we thought, and there is a very nice work, more
recent, by Jason Locasale, following Hoffman's original work
on methionine restriction. We haven't done anything on
diet in vivo.
We are worried that the confounders will be too many,
by changing the diet rather than going directly for the genetics downstream.
But it's definitely something we-- and I know a lot of people are doing
it, are using changes in diet to try to modulate cancer
growth. We haven't explored it in the lab, but definitely something we
keep it in mind, of course.
Hi, very interesting talk. I was wondering if you
think that maybe the serine dependency of the
tumor cells is already
in subpopulations of cells in the primary
tumor that makes them different?
Excellent question, too.
We didn't look that hard at single-cell level to
tell you if by single cell-- And actually, I look at a couple of single-cell
databases, and the resolution was not good enough for them to tell
me that they see enough expression in some cells to
suggest that the cells are already present there.
Again, from the way we did the analysis and the way we see the transcription
factor going up, we believe that this is happening at the metastasis.
We don't think this is a subpopulation that already exists in the primary tumor,
but I cannot rule it out. Yeah, it's a good question.
Last question. Bino, rapidly. We need
to move on.
So in your depth map, you had P300 actually in the opposite direction.
Do you think it's surprising or it's just like-
Excellent question, and we didn't look at them.
It was easier to follow the ones that are up because we could knock them down.
But yeah, we should be looking at them today
Okay. We will move to the next speaker, which is
Pankaj Singh from the University of
Oklahoma.
Let me see if I get this right. There you go.
Good afternoon, everyone. It's an honor to be presenting our work here.
I have nothing to disclose.
You all already introduced pancreatic cancer and how it's so
lethal. I would like to point out that among various
factors that contribute to lethality, of course, late diagnosis and
early metastasis is one of them, and that's in fact one of the
topic for discussion today. So when you think about
how tumor cells reprogram and adapt to the microenvironment,
we think of stresses in the microenvironment such as acidosis,
hypoxia, nutrient deprivation, and of course, there's constant feedback
and interactions with stromal cells.
And all these interactions contribute to the metabolic fitness, which in a
sense governs how cells are going to behave under certain
conditions. So with that, we have been focusing in the lab over
several years on multiple factors such as hypoxia, acidosis,
stromal metabolite exchange, as well as alterations in nutrient cycles.
So with that, one of the particular pathways that we have been focusing on is
purine metabolism and how it impacts cell proliferation, growth,
immunovision, as well as therapy resistance, among other
things. For today's talk, I'm going to be specifically talking about
purine metabolism.
So just to evaluate, what role does purine metabolism play
in pancreatic adenocarcinoma? We looked at existing data
sets and comparing TCGA cohorts as well as CPTAC cohorts, we
do see the purine metabolism gene signatures to be
significantly induced in PDAC.
And if you look at the carbon flux from glucose to
PRPP, and then IMP, which then goes eventually into
GDP or ADP pathways,
there are multiple enzymes that contribute to this flux.
And one of the enzymes that we have focused on is IMPDH or IMP
dehydrogenase, which converts IMP into XMP.
And this was an obvious choice because when we look at
dependencies in DepMap, as Raul also alluded to earlier,
we noticed a number of nuclear bile acids pathway enzymes were
showing vulnerabilities, and IMPDH2, in fact, was one of them,
against which there are existing FDA-approved therapies that are
available.
So with that in mind, we looked at IMPDH2 expression
in different data sets, including TCGA, and it was
significantly induced in multiple cohorts.
Looking at survival, we also noticed that patients that had high
tumoral IMPDH2 levels did have overall poor
prognosis, which was statistically significant, and also
confirmed that at protein level in CPTAC and KU proteomics cohorts,
that did show a poor prognosis overall
in patients that had high IMPDH2 expression.
So with that, looking into some of the single-cell cohorts,
we noted that compared to normal, it is significantly induced
in the tumors, and it's induced in multiple cell types across
the PDAC tumors, but the malignant cells that actually don't
exist in normal pancreas, they do have a quite robust expression of
IMPDH2, among some other cells in the microenvironment as
well.
So with that, there is another isoform that actually contributes the same
function, which is IMPDH1. And, unlike
IMPDH2, IMPDH1 is neither induced nor
correlates significantly with
prognosis, either at mRNA or protein levels.
So with that,
the question was, does it contribute to metastasis in any
capacity? And for that, we looked at metastatic cohorts,
and we evaluated the existing data sets
for single-cell RNA-seq by looking for purine base in this
gene enrichments. And looking so, we noted there was
significant enrichment in purine base in the gene expression
profiles, in liver mets, adrenal gland metastasis, as
well as omental mets.
And we also tested using spatial transcriptomics data sets.
There were two data sets that were published recently, and both liver mets and
lymph node mets actually show increased enrichment of purine base in the
genes. However, I would like to point out that not all metastasis are
actually created equal. So patients that do have multiple
organ site mets, they do have overall worse prognosis.
However, if you compare other sites, and in this
study from a French cohort, liver mets actually
tops in terms of worse overall outcomes for patients compared to
peritoneal and lung. And there are multiple other studies that have done similar
profiling, be it bone metastasis, be it lymph node
metastasis, liver metastasis does happen to have overall poor prognosis.
And not only that, liver-only patients actually do
top the list. They actually have the highest incidence
compared to other organ sites. So with that, we primarily
focused on PDAC mets.
In comparing different genes in the purine base in this pathway,
we do see significant enrichment in the single-cell cohort
for multiple genes compared to the primary pancreatic
adenocarcinoma.
So with that,
we compared IMPDH1 and IMPDH2 expression
in tumor cells, per se, and we noted that
the liver mets do have actually a higher number of cells that show increased
expression. Of course, expression is high in primary PDAC as well,
but comparatively, lymph node mets in the spatial
transcriptomics data sets, they do have more cells expressing, but not quite to the
same extent.However, IMPDH1, which is the other
enzyme that catalyzes the same reaction, was not detected.
So with that, the obvious question was, is it actually a viable target for PDAC?
So, from the therapeutic standpoint, as I mentioned, we did
observe that IMPDH does present vulnerability, at least in the cell
lines. And there is an existing inhibitor which is
FDA-approved, that is mycophenolic acid.
It's actually a non-competitive inhibitor of IMPDH, and
it is an FDA-approved immunosuppressant which is used to prevent organ
transplant rejection, and it's also been
tried in multiple malignancies across the different cancer
types. However, it doesn't have a whole lot of efficacy as a
mono agent. But now there has been some focus on combination
therapies, and there are efforts underway testing
MPA in combination with temozolomide for GBM patients.
So with that,
we reasoned, well, it doesn't have efficacy as a single agent either due to
resistance, inherent or acquired.
And we tried to model acquired resistance by taking human as well
as mouse PDAC cells and selecting them to increasing dose of
MPA. And after confirming resistance, we selected that to metabolic and
RNC studies to identify
vulnerabilities in the combinatorial therapies.
Just to give you a glimpse of the timeline, it took us nearly a
year to be able to get to a
significant increase in the doses that these cells were actually able to
resist.
And this is just shown here.
There was roughly a 20-fold increase in IC50
enhanced poor responsiveness
after some of these treatments.
So with that, to investigate the mechanistic pathways, we simply
asked what sort of pathways are actually perturbed, and we did see
quite dramatic degrees in OXPHOS as well as reactive oxygen
species pathways, which suggests that these cells perhaps
have some ability to resist to some of these mechanisms.
And just comparing cells with MPA treatment versus
controls, we did see a number of genes that were induced, and top
three, in fact, were in the same pathway.
VOLA2, which is involved in the assembly of iron sulfur clusters in
the cytoplasm, and SLC7A11, which is an exit transporter
for cysteine uptake, and you already heard a little bit about that from Raul.
And
cystathionine gamma-hydrolase, which converts cystathionine
into cysteine, and they both actually converge on glutathione
synthesis.
So with that, we also looked at IMPDH expression itself, if that actually presents
a recent mechanism. However, that actually was not perturbed
upon treatment with MPA.
So then comparing the metabolic profiles in the resistant and sensitive cells,
we saw a number of metabolic pathways that are perturbed.
I would like to point out there were actually always changes in cysteine and
cystine profiles. And
just to point out, cysteine to cystine ratio in both cell lines
through our mass spec studies showed significant increase,
and that suggests that these cells are actually able to sustain somewhat
of a
reductive stage. And that's also intriguing because
a lot of chemotherapies work by imparting oxidative damage in
cancer cells. And these cells somehow have the ability to
resist that, which is not surprising.
But regardless, when we combine our metabolomics and transcriptomics
dataset, the top pathway that was perturbed actually
came out to be glutathione metabolism, which we kind of predicted.
So to use an orthogonal pathway to
evaluate some of these vulnerabilities, we
already have CFEC cells in the lab that were optimized for
the Bruno library
workflow, and we tested these with the MS or MPA
treatment for 14 days with the hope that that actually mimics a little bit of a
resistance profile. And we compared the genes that
were actually contributing to some of these vulnerabilities.
So in that screen,
interestingly enough, one of the top genes was actually GPX4.
GPX4 or glutathione peroxidase is actually an
enzyme that utilizes glutathione, and it converts lipid
hydroperoxides to lipid alcohol,
essentially reversing lipid peroxidation.
And this also shows a convergence of the pathway that we have been seeing.
Exit transporter system or even
CDH, they contribute to glutathione
production, and that's utilized by GPX4 to then counter
lipid peroxidation and hence resisting ferroptosis.
So with that in mind, we tried to confirm some of these
findings. And GPX4 showed up as a vulnerability,
and we tested expression in sensitive and MP-resistant cells.
Although one of the cell lines did show an increase in GPX4 expression per se,
other did not. But regardless, the SLC7A11 expression was
consistently higher
in both resistant cell lines that we tested.
So with that, we evaluated if targeting
these pathways particularly can help sensitize cells to
inhibition of pyrimidine biosynthesis with MPA.
And for that, we utilized sulfasalazine, which is already FDA-approved agent
for rheumatoid arthritis, and RSL3, which is actually a tool compound
to target GPX4 itself.
So treating
the sensitive and resistant cells with sulfasalazine, we actually saw
there was nearly an order of magnitude decrease in the
sensitivity, sorry, in the resistant or increased sensitivity
in the resistant cells when they were treated with sulfasalazine by
itself.So, to again further
confirm that by targeting GPX4 itself, because we used
CFPAC1 cells in the screen, we treated them with different doses
of MPA or RSL3 itself. And while RSL3
itself didn't have a
whole lot of activity, it did sensitize these cells further to MPA
at almost every single dose.
We further confirmed that in the KPC as well as to
13 sensitive and resistant cells.
And sensitive cells, of course, are responses to MPA,
here both KPC and SL13. The resistant cells do not actually show a whole lot of
resistant profile. But when you combine that with the RSL3, there is actually
increase in sensitivity to MPA per se.
So to model that in animal models, we utilized
C57 black 6 mice and
injecting them with KPC line subtropical ly, and seven days later,
treated them with MPA or sulfasalazine.
And at the end of it, we euthanized the mice to compare tumor
burden. And evaluating the tumor volume
and tumor weight, we noted that even in the resistant cells,
they don't really respond to sulfasalazine.
Sorry, MPA. Sulfasalazine does show some responsiveness, and the
combination shows more robust effect.
However, we did not see any statistically
significant difference between sulfasalazine alone or the combination treated
cells. So we reasoned because in metastatic
conditions, there were more cells that actually expressed or
higher levels of
IMPDH2, perhaps primary tumor is not the right context, and
hence we switched to metastatic models.
So one of the limitations of studying PDAC is there aren't really
that many models that truly recapitulate metastases.
So for that, we switched to, in essence,
splenic injection models, in which you can actually inject
tumor cells, and you can clip the spleen and inject in one half,
and then you can subsequently clip the splenic vein
and artery and remove the other
injected part of the spleen itself.
So it fairly recapitulates
the metastatic colonization. It does not recapitulate the extravasation part and
how tumor cells get out from the primary tumor and home to the liver.
But because you're putting them in the circulation right on, it still
recapitulates the colonization component of the metastasis.
So just to confirm that we actually were observing similar
pathways there, we confirmed through special metabolomics
levels of different purine metabolites, including IMP, GMP, ADP, and GDP.
And as shown here with cytocaine 90, and these are tumor cell
regions in the liver. That's the primary tumor.
And we do see significant enrichment for these metabolites
compared to primary tumor itself.
In contrast, if you look at the pyrimidines that we were able to detect,
we did not see any enrichment in the match.
In fact, primary tumors did show somewhat of an increased levels for
CMPA
and maybe even to some extent UMP.
So with that, comparing the metastatic
potential in these cells, we noted that in the combination treated
cells, the macromets were largely gone,
and this also corresponded to decreased liver weight in these
animals that were treated with combination therapy.
And when we compared micrometastases, the
micrometastases nodules, as well as the area of metastasis were significantly
decreased in the combination treated
mice compared to individual
controls, which suggests that I think this is likely more
efficient in the metastatic setting, at least for the liver cancer models.
So with that, to put things in
clinical perspective, MPA has been tried in clinical trials
as a monoagent therapy, particularly in the context of
neoadjuvant therapy. And it was considered as an
anti-angiogenic therapy.
There was this trial that was run off of Hopkins.
In 2013, this was published, and it
was
administered to 12 patients at two different doses.
And 15 days later,
the tumor was resected. It showed good tolerance in patients, but there
was no efficacy. And again, it really suggests the same thing.
As a monoagent, it does not have any clinical
relevance. However, as a combination therapy, and particularly in
the setting of metastasis, we can actually expect quite a bit of
efficacy. And of course, just
recently,
we had that phase three trial results that actually showed very promising
outcomes with the KRAS inhibitors.
So I don't think this is going to be a
unique separate therapy, but rather in combination with the existing
KRAS inhibitors, I think to target specifically some of these metastatic
patients, I think we could perhaps have some clinical relevance here.
So just to summarize, IMPDH2 is upregulated in primary and
metastatic PDAC and correlates with overall poorer prognosis.
And prolonged exposure to MPA induces an anti-protopic
response in PDAC cells. And ferroptosis inducers could actually sensitize
PDAC tumors to MPA. And
inhibition of ferroptosis and purine
biosynthesis
inhibiting agents can diminish metastasis, at least in the PDAC
models. So with that, I would like to thank all the people that contributed to this
work. This was primarily led by Drew Labrecque who is
a grad student who recently graduated
from the lab, as well as our collaborator, the Laboratory Program in
Nebraska, as well as our funding from NIH and ARNERT.
With that, I would like to also advertise we are currently recruiting in our
department at University of Oklahoma Health Sciences.
If you have interest, please feel free to reach out.
This is at all levels.And with that, I thank you for your attention.
I'll be happy to take any questions.
Thank you, Pankaj.
Questions? Yeah, it's interesting that
you get expression of IMPDH2 but not one.
I
feel like we've seen that before in maybe tumors with high levels of
Mec. And an experiment that we never did was to knock out
IMPDH2 and see if you can rescue with IMPDH1.
They should be in the same compartment, but maybe there's something special about
IMPDH2. I wonder,
have you thought about looking at that, too?
So that's actually a very interesting point.
Most of the studies that we carried out were with MPA.
So right now we are actually trying to do knockdowns and knockouts for IMPDH2
first and see if there is a rescue. At least in the
recent models that we tested, there was no
induction from either of IMPDH, but that could be just because
MPA does target both isoforms. So,
that's why we perhaps don't have any rescue per se, but if we target
MPDH2 as a
gene itself, there could definitely be some compensation from that.
Yes.
Wonderful work.
Have you thought about combining with chemotherapy in order to
try and capture the cell?
After the chemotherapy, the tumor's trying to grow back, and
presumably is replicating and has a high demand for
nucleotides, and therefore could be more vulnerable,
whereas in the single agent setting, where the cell may
have a smaller growth fraction, maybe that's a source of the resistance.
That's actually a very good point.
So, if I think about just MPA
treatment alone as a combination therapy, what we saw was
actually these cells were able to
maintain increased reductive environment.
So that would actually argue against trying typical conventional
chemotherapies, which do actually act through multiple modes, but
primarily by increasing oxidative damage in the cells.
However, I guess as a triple combination, it could work
when we are also trying to inhibit ferroptosis, and then we can actually have
more efficacy as a single agent. And I do believe, I think, particularly if
we are trying to attempt to target primary tumor, I think it has to be with
one of the maybe KRAS inhibitors, and then in combination with
that.
But it's going to be primarily in the metastatic setting.
And I'm not really sure if different organ site metastases are
also having different response to particularly this combination, but at
least we do have some expression signatures that are showing
induction, but some variations as well.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Hi, Pankaj. Really great work.
I was just wondering, in the MPA resistant cell lines, do they have any
difference in growth rates and
potentially protein synthesis rates as another mechanism
of potentially conserving cysteine and
allowing it to build up?
That's actually a good point. They do actually grow a little slower.
So,
that could actually be happening in some capacity, I suppose.
So there is some decrease in growth rate and hence likely some decreased
protein synthesis as well that may allow them to also conserve
some cysteine levels by themselves. That's a good point.
Hi. That is very interesting and ardent work.
And I noticed that in the initial screening, the dependency
of the IMPDH2 is much higher than that of the
PPAT and the PFAS. Both of the latter are believed to
be much more upstream and rate-limiting enzymes in de
novo purine synthesis. So, do you have
any thoughts or insights about the mechanism that determines
the dependency on different enzymes?
That's a good question. I think at some point, different enzymatic
pathways bifurcate. Of course,
cells do show decent amount of dependency on IMPDH2, but we
chose that primarily because there are existing FDA-approved agents against
it.
If we had the ability to develop agents, we could definitely look into some other
enzymes as well. But I do believe, I think, the
essential enzymatic nodes in any given pathway are going
to be somewhat preserved. And if it is
primarily because of nucleotide levels, I guess at
whatever level you're going to be able to inhibit, you're going to have efficacy.
It may vary in primary versus metastatic tumors.
There has been multiple other talks around how
salvage path-- There was actually a talk during the educational session by Matt
Vander Heiden, who was
talking about how there could be more dependence on the salvage pathway, among
other things. So, I think the dependence may
switch between the tumor site at any given
location versus metastatic versus primary.
But in essence, if you are inhibiting
enzymatic pathway and there's absolute dependence, you may have same efficacy
whether you have started upstream or downstream.
But there could be some ancillary reactions that actually are contributing to
the vulnerability, and that could be essentially different depending on what the
direction might be.
All right. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay. We'll move to the last speaker of the session.
Here.
Raul Ramos.
Thanks a lot, Raul, for inviting me to come talk today, and it's great to see
everybody. Good afternoon.
Okay. These are my disclosures.
And, I'm not actually going to talk about metastasis that much, but
we got interested in nucleotide metabolism by studying metastasis, so let me
start there.
We're interested in metabolic pathways that promote metastasis.
And the way we study that in patientsIs to infuse people
intraoperatively with carbon-13 glucose or other isotope-labeled nutrients
while their tumors are being surgically resected.
And then we can use the labeling features and metabolites extracted from the
tumor to infer which metabolic pathways are active in the tumor
as the tumor is growing in the patient.
So we've done this hundreds of times in hundreds of patients at
this point using different tracers.
And the story that has emerged from that is that
tumors growing at the site of initiation are highly variable in terms of
their mitochondrial metabolism, and they can tolerate quite low levels
of mitochondrial metabolism in order to initiate and grow.
However,
tumors
that have metastasized or are going to metastasize tend to have a
shift towards higher mitochondrial metabolism, and
electron transport chain complex one seems to be particularly
important because
that complex is both necessary and sufficient to
induce metastasis in mouse models.
And that last part in particular was the work of Divya Baswata,
who was a great PhD student in the lab.
So variable levels of mitochondrial metabolism depending on the stage of the
tumor. And that got us interested in asking
which metabolic pathways are most sensitive to differences
in mitochondrial function. And so we've studied that in several ways,
but basically, the answer that arose for us
is that the way that cells maintain their pools of purine
nucleotides is incredibly sensitive to the level of mitochondrial
function.
So,
we've been talking about this a little bit for this session, but just to
remind you,
cells have two different ways they can make purine nucleotides.
They can build them from scratch, that's called the de novo purine
biosynthesis pathway, the de novo pathway.
Or they can salvage them, which means that the blue part here, that is
the purine base,
is effectively scavenged from the degradation of other purine
nucleotides.
And so,
what we and others have observed is that the level of
mitochondrial function basically dictates which pathway
cells use. Cells that have healthy mitochondria tend
to prefer the de novo pathway, whereas suppression of
mitochondrial function,
at least in part through redox effects, increases
the need for the salvage pathway. So mitochondria
dictate this
choice.
So,
let me just give a little bit more detail about these pathways.
And they're complicated, but they're going to be outlined in black
for the de novo pathway and red for the salvage pathway for the rest of the talk.
This is the de novo pathway. It's a long pathway, and it requires a
significant amount of energy and nutrients.
It starts with this enzyme right here called PPAT.
Somebody just mentioned this enzyme, which takes an activated pentose,
PRPP, and converts it into PRA, which is a
labile intermediate. And PRA then proceeds down the
pathway to inosine monophosphate, a purine nucleotide, and the other
purine nucleotides. That's the salvage pathway, energetically
demanding 10 steps here, and it requires the nutrients shown in the
boxes.
And in contrast, the salvage pathway is just one enzyme, HPRT1,
which takes that activated pentose, adds a purine base like
hypoxanthine, and you get right back to IMP.
So, a fast and cheap pathway versus a long and highly
regulated pathway. And so the question arises of how cells switch between
de novo synthesis and salvage. Biochemically, of course, we know
something about this. We know that the de novo pathway is under feedback
inhibition, at least in part at the level of PPAT, but the reality
is that it takes very high levels of nucleotides to achieve full
levels of inhibition. Seems like there might be other components
involved in this regulatory mechanism.
And so we went looking for those regulatory factors.
And one way you can do that is with a CRISPR screen
for genes that confer sensitivity or resistance
to thiopurine chemotherapeutics like 6-thioguanine or 6TG.
These were developed by Ellian and Hitchings back in the
1950s.
The
thiopurine bases are not toxic, but they get
scavenged by HPRT1 to make thiopurine nucleotides,
and those have two effects. They inhibit the de novo pathway, and they incorporate
into nucleic acids, and together those kill the cell.
So a screen for,
let's say, CRISPR guides that confer resistance
to 6-thioguanine
could identify genes involved in salvage or genes involved in
inhibition of the de novo pathway.
And these are the two things that we wanted to find.
And we were lucky because David Root's lab had done a screen just like this several
years ago, and they identified guides against two genes that
conferred resistance to thiopurines.
One was HPRT1, which of course is predicted.
And the other was a gene called N-U-D-T5
or NUDT5. And we validated both. Here are the wild
type cells that are sensitive to 6TG.
The HPRT1 deficient cells are completely resistant, and the NUDT5 deficient
cells are also quite resistant.
So what is NUDT5?
It's an enzyme. It belongs to the nudix hydrolase family, and it has a
known catalytic function to cleave ADP-ribose,
which is a byproduct of NAD metabolism, into
AMP and ribose 5-phosphate.
So Zheng Wu, the postdoc working on this project, thought this would be
easy to figure out because ribose 5-phosphate is the
precursor of PRPP, and that's the substrate of HPRT1.
So maybe what NUDT5 is doing is just providing the pentose for
the salvage pathway.
But that turned out to be wrong because reconstituting the NUDT5
deficient cellsWith wild type NUDT5
or an allele that is catalytically inactive, that's the
E112Q mutation, are equally good at restoring sensitivity to
60G. So that means that whatever NUDT5 is doing, it has nothing to do with
its catalytic function. And in fact, we also just tested the
HPRT1 reaction using isotope tracers, and it's completely
insensitive to presence or absence of NUDT5.
So something else is going on here.
So then we studied the de novo pathway, which is again shown
here in black, again with isotope tracing, but now using N15
labeled glutamine with a label in the gamma position.
That nitrogen gets incorporated twice into AMP that is
synthesized by the de novo pathway, and that's very easy to follow by mass
spectrometry. Okay. So the gray bars here show you that cells
with wild type NUDT5 avidly use the de
novo synthesis pathway and completely shut it
off when 60G is present. That was expected, but the
NUDT5 deficient cells can't do that, and they keep on using the de
novo pathway, even with the drug on board.
So there's a difference in sensitivity.
Okay, so in this system, what NUDT5 is doing is really
dictating whether cells can turn off the de novo
pathway when purines or thiopurines are present.
And
I think it's important that that's not just a fluke
of these thiopurine chemotherapeutic reagents because it also
occurs when you give natural purine bases like hypoxanthine.
This is an N15 labeling time course.
Here you can see the cells with wild type NUDT5 in gray
shutting off the de novo pathway when you add hypoxanthine.
But the cells lacking NUDT5, they keep on using
the de novo synthesis pathway.
And
that is why the cells are resistant
to 60G. A little bit of a side note, but I sort of always
assumed that the major mechanism of cancer cell
killing with these drugs was DNA damage.
Okay, that may be true in some systems, but at least in our hands, the
amount of DNA damage is no different in cells that do or don't have
NUDT5. Okay, what is different is whether they can use the de novo
pathway. And so we use these two drugs, lemotrexal and
methotrexate, both of which block the de novo pathway.
And as I said before, cells lacking NUDT5 are
fairly resistant to 60G. They're also fairly resistant to
inhibitors of the de novo pathway, but if you combine them together, now
60G becomes toxic. So what's keeping the cells alive is that
residual let's say, persistence of the de novo synthesis pathway.
Okay, anyway, mechanism. How is NUDT5 doing this if it doesn't require
the catalytic activity? It turns out NUDT5 physically
interacts with PPAT. That's the enzyme that initiates the de
novo pathway.
And we picked up this interaction
initially, computationally. Our
collaborator, Qian Song at UT Southwestern, uses
co-evolutionary signals to infer protein-protein interactions,
and she was the first one who alerted us to this possible interaction.
The AlphaFold model here predicts that residue
R70 on NUDT5 lies right in the interaction
interface.
So we generated cells with FLAG-tagged PPAT and
then showed that PPAT can pull down wild type NUDT5
or the catalytic mutant, but it can't pull down
NUDT5 that contains an arginine to alanine
mutation at residue 70. Okay, I should just
add that that mutation, the R70A mutation in
NUDT5, we don't think disrupts the structure of the protein
because it's still catalytically active, but it can't bind to PPAT anymore.
Okay, and that interaction is critical for this ability to shut off the de novo
synthesis pathway. Here are cells lacking NUDT5, okay, which keep
using de novo synthesis, okay, when you treat them with 60G.
I showed you that before. If you add back wild type or catalytically
inactive NUDT5, they shut it off. But if you add back the mutant that
doesn't bind PPAT, they keep using the de novo synthesis
pathway.
Okay.
I should say that in vitro, we validated this is a direct
interaction using recombinant PPAT and NUDT5.
Okay, so they bind directly. And then this is an in vitro
enzymatic assay using NUDT5, PPAT,
and then we added PRP and glutamine, the two substrates of the PPAT
reaction, just to use mass spec to monitor the production of glutamate.
And what you can see is that if you add in wild type NUDT5, it
inhibits quite potently, okay, about 80% of PPAT's
enzymatic activity, but the binding mutant has no effect.
Okay.
So what about in vivo? So we generated xenografts from those
same four cell lines, okay,
cell lines that contain no NUDT5,
wild type NUDT5, or either of the two mutants, waited for the
tumors to grow up, and then treated the mice either with a vehicle or with 60G.
Cells that don't have NUDT5 or have NUDT5 that can't
bind
to PPAT are completely insensitive to 60G,
whereas
as long as NUDT5 can bind to PPAT, the tumors are quite sensitive.
So this is a drug that's been around since the 1950s, and
NUDT5 is,
I think, a key component in determining whether the
drug can be effective.
All right, so I'm just going to summarize a little bit about the biochemical
mechanism. We're still working on this, but
the issue seems to be the oligomeric state of
PPAT. So it's been known since the 1970s
that PPAT is most active when it's a dimer.And less
active when it's a higher order oligomer,
such as a tetramer. And NUDT15
induces PPAT tetramerization. That's shown
here in
basically in a glutaraldehyde
assay. You can see increased tetramerization of PPAT in the
presence of wild type or catalytically inactive NUDT5.
But the mutant that doesn't bind PPAT, now PPAT
is mostly in the active dimeric state. Okay.
So,
I think what that means is that when NUDT5 can bind
PPAT, PPAT tetramerizes, and that
allows the abundance of purine
nucleotides to shut off the de novo pathway at the level,
at least in part, of PPAT enzymatic activity.
Okay? If NUDT5 doesn't bind, PPAT retains its dimeric active
form, and the de novo pathway keeps going.
So,
I would love to know what is the biochemical triggering
mechanism to induce tetramerization and
maybe even more proximally, why NUDT5 binds.
This is not constitutive, okay? And the fraction
of PPAT in the cell that is
bound to NUDT5 is extremely low, even in situations
where PPAT is inactive. So it seems like maybe a
kiss-and-run phenomenon, and we don't know what the biochemical trigger is.
We know that we can trigger the interaction by giving purine bases in
the presence of HPRT1. That suggests that it probably involves
these purine nucleotides or possibly a drop in PRPP or maybe
both.
Okay. But we need more biochemical insight into how this is happening, and I think
this is worth pursuing because this could provide a definitive mechanism of purine
homeostasis, which has been missing, I think, since this pathway was
worked out about 80 years ago.
Okay. And I just want to point out these other two great papers here,
that reported a role for NUDT5 in regulating de novo purine
biosynthesis
right around the same time we did.
Okay. Last thing to say is that,
it has to do with the way the purine biosynthesis pathway actually
operates in intact cells. Okay? I find this quite
interesting. So there are six enzymes, PPAT and
five other ones, that catalyze the 10 reactions between
PRPP and IMP. All right? And when
the pathway is active, they are co-localized in a
cytosolic super complex that Steven Benkovic named the
purinosome. And, the purinosome is thought
to exist to channel
phosphoribosylamine, that labile product of the PPAT reaction,
down to IMP.
Okay.
When purines are scarce,
you can see these purinosomes forming in cells.
They're these punctate dots here, and they show up because
one of the enzymes in the de novo synthesis pathway's been tagged with GFP.
And then if you add purines back, they just dissipate over the course of a
few minutes. Okay. So it's quite dynamic.
And we think part of what NUDT5 is doing is determining the
dissipation rate of these purinosomes.
I say that because cells that lack NUDT5 or that
express the PPAT binding mutants
inappropriately
allow purinosomes to persist. Here, the purinosomes are these black
dots, even when nucleotides are present, and that's quantified
here, and you can see the high level of purinosomes
in the R70A mutant expressing
cells. Okay. So,
two mechanisms by which NUDT5
regulates purine metabolism. One is the direct mechanism on PPAT's
biochemical activity, and the other is in the ability to
allow the purinosome to dissipate when
purines are abundant. And I have to say, I don't know which one is the dominant
mechanism. What we're trying to do now is to identify PPAT mutants that
retain their catalytic activity, retain NUDT5 binding,
okay, but cannot associate with the purinosome, and that would allow us to
know whether effective purinosome assembly is actually
required for efficient de novo purine
synthesis. Okay. Does this matter in people?
It does seem to matter in people. This is a beautiful study from Jun Yang
at
St. Jude's, and what he did was to genotype
patients.
These were pediatric patients with acute
lymphoblastic leukemia,
that were receiving 6-mercaptopurine, a different
thiopurine. And the question was: Are there sequence variants associated
with anything in the nudix family, okay, that is
associated with drug responses? And he found
an intergenic variant in an
enhancer that regulates the level of NUDT15 expression.
And what the graph shows is that patients that have one or two copies of that
variant have a lower 6-MP dose intensity.
Basically, what that means is that if you have that
variant, you're more likely to experience myelosuppression
at the same dose of 6-MP. Okay. The higher the level
of NUDT5 expression, the more toxic the drug is.
It's probably more toxic to the leukemia cells, but in this study, also
toxic to the normal cells.
Okay. So let me just
bring it back to metastasis for one second.
We know that there is this tendency to trend towards increased
higher mitochondrial metabolism, and we think that's important for metastasis,
including in people. The question that we have to address now is
whether that transition also involves a change in the
mode of purine metabolism. I think this is plausible because
maintaining purine pools, we think, is a metabolic
bottleneckThat cells have to be able to overcome
during metastasis, and the ability to maintain flexibility about the way these
two compensatory pathways are regulated
may give cells a way to
tolerate that.
Okay, in the last minute, I just want to back out for one more second and just say
something
else about the metabolic network. The network is there.
Okay, that is a poster that hangs in my office that I look at every day.
And
what's a little bit depressing about the poster is that almost every reaction
on there is older than me.
Okay? And that leads
to the perception that we know everything there is to know about
metabolism. I think that that's not true,
and I would bet that most of the people in here also think that that's not true.
And because I think there's a big gap between
knowing the enzymes in the pathway and knowing how they're spatially
organized to maximize their regulation. Okay?
It's a little bit like knowing all of the pieces in the Lego set, but not knowing
what the Lego set is supposed to look like when it's built out into three
dimensions. And so, I'll just
maybe say that I think there's a lot more to learn.
One aspect of that is that if you think about the pathway, you get the
impression that all pathways
operate like this with soluble substrates and
enzymes that have to encounter each other stochastically by
diffusing through an aqueous milieu.
When in reality, I would bet that there are a lot of pathways that actually operate
more like the purinosome, with transient complexes that come together and come
apart in order to regulate flux, because that would give you two very different
states of metabolic activity through a pathway, even when all the
enzymes are present. Okay?
This is an old idea that goes back to the 1970s at least,
but we have identified very few of these super complexes,
and even fewer that have any role in human
physiology. But I think now is a good time to go looking for them again.
Co-evolutionary analysis is a powerful way to infer
where interactions may occur, and human genetics gives us
insight into when missense variants in
protein-protein interaction domains actually cause metabolic
disturbance in people. Okay? So this is something that we will be working on for
the next few years. And let me just stop and thank the people who did all
the work.
For the purine metabolism, basically all Zheng and Fong, two great postdocs in my
lab.
And
I want to thank the patients and families who participated in
our clinical studies. Thanks very much.
Questions for Ralph?
Great talk. Omid Tajiasani from Case Western.
I had a question regarding the TCA cycle activity on metastatic
tumors. I was wondering if these tumors already have higher TCA
on their primary site, and then they're going to a new host organs,
or they exchange that or convert their metabolism when they arrive at the
host organs.
Yeah, this is a great question, and
I think it's the former.
And the reason I say that is because both in lung cancer
and now in
clear cell renal cell carcinoma, we've sort of gone back and looked
at the level of variable mitochondrial metabolism and then followed
outcomes of those patients. And in both cases,
the level of it, to be really precise about
this, it's the level of TCA cycle intermediate labeling with
carbon-13 during an infusion of something like carbon-13 glucose.
That level of labeling, basically, if you just dichotomize
the group into ones that are higher or lower than the median, in both
cases, in the primary tumor, high levels of labeling predict worse
outcomes. And the worse outcomes in those two diseases basically means whether or
not you got metastasis.
Thank you.
Hi, Ralph. This is very elegant work, and I'm very familiar with
the paper because I presented it in our lab's journal club several months before.
This is when you get a really hard question.
Okay, so I have-
Supplemental data, figure 10C, you should...
Yeah, because I work on how pyrimidine synthase regulates the chemo sensitivity.
So I have two brief questions. The first is in the GCI paper published by
the lab in the Sinjude. They point out
that in the leukemia, the NUDT15 also regulates the
salvage pathway activity. But in your paper, in hela cells, it has
nothing to do with the salvage pathway activity.
Is there any cell type-specific regulation of how
NUDT5 regulates purine synthesis?
Yeah, that's a great question. I think there probably is, and my guess is that
it comes down to the
ability of a cell to engage the pentose phosphate pathway to make an alternative
source of PRPP. I mean, we would think of that as the primary source of
PRPP, and the amount of ADP-ribose that's present.
So it's possible that in leukemia cells, there's enough ADP-ribose around, you get
a meaningful amount of ribose 5-phosphate and
PRPP. My guess is that's what's going on.
Okay, thank you. And the second question is that I remember also in the paper,
there's data showing that the NUDT5 mediated chemo
resistance is thiopurine specific, but not for
cis-platinum radiation and other things like that.
But for all the DNA damage, they require
a substantial nucleotide pool to mediate a
DNA repair. So I'm curious why
this cannot be applied to
other kinds of DNA damage.
Yes.I don't have a complete answer to that question.
My guess is that the reason it works with thiopurines is because you get such a
potent suppression of de novo purine synthesis, and that really
becomes
part of the mechanism of cell death.
Whereas with cisplatin, et cetera, you're directly damaging the DNA,
and that doesn't cause that same problem with purine synthesis.
So I would guess, and I have not tested this, but that in
cisplatin treatment, et cetera, the cells can still synthesize purines de
novo, and therefore, you don't get any benefit out of losing NUDT15.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
That was great, Ralph.
When I was watching you go through this, I just seen it before, it made me
think about another regulatory mechanism through the
presence of superoxide and titration of the effect as a
function of removing hypoxanthine.
And I'm wondering, have you
put the cells
under mitochondrial stress, or you drive the react?
Should we reinterpret the way we think about the pentose phosphate pathway?
Yeah.
Ross.
That's a really
insightful point.
The situation where the need for HPRT1 is the highest, that would be the
most efficient mechanism of getting rid of hypoxanthine is the
state where
the electron transport chain is inhibited. Okay?
So if it was really just about making nucleotides, you should
be able to completely correct the effect by giving nucleosides back.
Yeah.
And you can't. You can take care of about half of the effect.
So there probably are other mechanisms, and this could be one of them.
Thanks for the question.
Really enjoyed your talk.
Does targeting complex one dissipate the
purinosome?
I
think
Stephen Bankovic's lab did that.
And I think what they found, interestingly, was that
purinosomes were stabilized under that state.
And it probably wasn't blocking complex one, I think it was
hypoxia. We can go back and look at the paper.
That,
to me, is unexpected.
And so I think there's probably something interesting there that should be studied
further. Thanks for the question.
Maybe I can ask a question, Ralph. So is there any
post-transfer modification in the purinosome partners that could perhaps be
utilized as a biomarker to predict the
response in patients?
Yeah. Could you repeat the first part again, Pankaj?
Is there any post-transfer modification in the
purinosome complex that's being perturbed by any
DUDT5 that could be used as a biomarker?
Yeah. It's a good question. There are some post-translational
modifications on NUDT15 that are known. There are phosphorylation sites.
But those are not involved in the de novo purine pathway
regulation as far as we can tell. The
mechanisms that allow the purinosome to be assembled
are still very unclear.
And,
as far as I know, there are no post-translational modifications
that have been identified so far. Okay.
It's possible that this acts more like
a
liquid phase separation or condensates,
in which case some of these proteins have intrinsically disordered regions.
And so it may be that
it's not a rigid association. That is
my guess, and I think that's sort of the way I think about these
super complexes, is that
bringing them together provides an advantage to the cell, but it's equally
important to get them apart quickly.
Because if it wasn't, then I think evolution would have fixed these catalytic
activities in the same polypeptide.
That was my question. Does it have IDRs, DUDT5?
What's that?
Intrinsic disorder regions.
Yeah. So some of these do. PPAT has one, for example.
Last question.
Hi. Great work. I really enjoyed the presentation.
Just one kind of broad question for the whole session.
Actually, we are talking about nucleotide, but I feel
like people are more actually interested in the purine instead of
pyrimidine. I know there are many work
from Bankovic group focused on the purinosome that will
couple to the mitochondria, the whole metabolism things.
Is that the
reason why we are more focused on the purine instead of pyrimidine, that
it's coupled with a broad metabolism pathway?
Or are there any other reasons? That's my question.
I think there's a lot of interest in pyrimidines also.
Yeah.
And my guess is that if they gave you 15 speakers it would have been more-
No
... it would've been more balanced.
Yeah.
There's interest in identifying situations where Brequinar, for
example, has been developed-
Yep
... clinically. And I also think the regulatory
properties of the pyrimidine pathway are equally interesting, too.
Yeah.
Actually, it was by chance. I didn't know that Ralph was going to talk about
purines when I selected. I knew Pankaj was going to,
but when he said the title, I said, "Okay, we will have a lot of purines."
But it wasn't planned like that. And again, if we have more
speakers, probably we'll have people talking about pyrimidines also.
Okay. Thank you.
And in-
I also work with the de novo purine synthesis pathway, so that's why
I ask.
I would like to comment. In our dependency,
at least in the DepMap screen in PDAC, we do see actually dependence in both
purines and pyrimidines. So I think we cannot rule out one
pathway compared to the other. But yeah, depending on the context, you
could perhaps look at one. At least in the metastatic setting,
we're seeing more purine dependency.
But I think from the primary goal standpoint, pyrimidines are also equally
important.
Okay. Thank you.
I think we need to move on. We don't have time for extra
discussion because all of us spoke and got a lot of
questions. But
I've been asked to leave the room because we need to start
preparing for the next session. Thank you everyone for
joining us today,
and it was really great with all the questions.
So hope to see you around in the rest of the meeting.